Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Marvel looks like they've cast
some of the new Fantastic
Four characters, including some metaphor
and literally big ones like Galactus.
So we'll break it all down.
we also learned a little bit
more about the actual story
and how they're going to explain
the MCU version of the Fantastic Four.
Only just showing up now, even though
they're supposed to have been in the MCU
this whole time.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We have Ahsoka episodes
coming up in a couple of weeks.
I'll be doing videos for all those Loki
season two episodes right after that.
So there's a bunch of big stuff coming up,
but you probably saw everyone talking
your feeds about the new casting reports.
It looks like Vanessa Kirby is going to be
the new Sue Storm, Invisible Woman.
She talked about it earlier
this year before they locked
all the characters down to Finally.
I mean, everyone wants you as invisible
Woman in Fantastic Four.
How is this training for preparing you
to do your own stunts?
And perhaps it would be an honor.
It would be an honor to place these doing
simulations.
She's
amazing. So they have complete honor.
It definitely feels like
she was very excited about the character,
like she was pretty sure she was going
to be the new Invisible Woman,
but they hadn't completely signed
the deal yet.
Like the ink wasn't dry.
I've done a couple videos about the movie
earlier this year.
And since then, what's changed
is the strike mostly delaying everything,
causing a bunch of scheduling problems.
So a bunch of actors that they supposedly
were going to use early
this year have since dropped out.
So if you didn't like the actors
that they picked before,
this is sort of like a blessing
in disguise for you Kevin Biggie
already said that the movie in the team,
that the whole vibe will be very different
from the previous Fantastic Four movies
just so that it feels like
a totally new thing while
still basing it on the original Fantastic
Four comics.
reportedly,
the way they're going to explain
how the team has been around
this whole time in the MCU,
but we're just learning about them
now is that they'll say they come from
the 1960s in wind up
traveling through time to present day
before the events of Avengers five,
Qing Dynasty in Avengers six Secret Wars,
supposedly
that's meant to pay off the Easter
egg from Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness
that was supposedly going to set up
what was going on
with the MCU version of the team,
because in the A3 eight version,
their backstory was a little bit different
during the movie, when
Doctor Strange jokes about the fantastic
Four charting during the 1960s,
there was a group called the Fantastic
Four in real life, but that was also
sort of a sly wink that Marvel was going
to say that the MCU version of the team
was from the 1960s.
Now, they didn't say whether or not
that also means that Doctor Doom
is also from the 1960s in the MCU,
because in the 838 universe,
there was a version of Doctor Doom
that they referenced when they were doing
commentary for the movie,
like when they were writing the film,
they envision that a lot of Doctor Doom
was going on the back
where there were like
ease drugs for his character,
even though they weren't planning on
introducing him during that movie.
Was shot a large personal interest.
Pleasure to work
with Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four.
So was John.
Oh, Steven.
teleportation device he uses to get into
the scene
is something we took from the comics.
That's Dr. Tune's Dr.
Doom's time door self
appreciate your platform, Stephen, but
it's not the Scarlet Witch that we fear
And while there's not Professor
X's first time on screen,
it is the first time we see that
over chair from the animated series
Reed Richards is my favorite
Marvel Comics characters.
It was a real honor to write his
first entry, I guess, here in the U.S..
I'm whether or not
the new MCU version of Doctor Doom
is also going to be from the 1960s.
It sounds like he would be because he's
such a huge part of their backstory.
But they might change that.
he's not supposed to be
in this first new Fantastic Four movie,
at least the MCU version, the character.
There's supposed to cast the character
in introduce him
in some other upcoming movie,
but they haven't said which one
that's going to be my early guess
right now is they probably intend on
using him in a story
that balances his magic and technology
more than the original Fantastic
Four movies did.
Those Fox movies never really got into Dr.
Doom being a powerful magic user.
He's meant to be near doctor
strange level in terms of ability.
He also comes from Ramani,
the same way that Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver have a lot of Romani
as part of their back story,
even though technically
their father is Magneto.
The difference is that he's
also a man of science.
Think Iron Man.
If he also used a lot of magic
to power his armor in, a lot of his plans
revolved around the use
or need for magic and mystical forces.
the funny thing about that is that there
was a what if story where Iron Man became
Doctor Strange and used a lot of magic
to power his Iron Man armor.
and there's a version of Tony
Stark in the Marvel comics
that eventually does
become Sorcerer Supreme.
They even had Easter Egg for that
during Avengers Infinity War,
where Iron Man wears
the cloak of levitation
and briefly becomes sort of doctor
strange in Doctor Strange wears
Iron Man's armor, becoming
what they call in the movie The Iron Mage.
They wound up deleting that scene.
So hopefully they'll bring that back
at some point.
Maybe in Avengers six Secret Wars,
maybe Avengers five, Qing Dynasty, just
like another universe version of Iron Man
that shows up who became Doctor Strange
in other universe version of Doctor
Strange that became Iron Man. But.
If they're doing more magic based doctor
doom stories when they start the character
out, the upcoming Fantastic Four movie
is more like a cosmic time travel movie.
It makes sense that they wouldn't
use him right away in that film.
Also, because they want to be different
from the original Fantastic Four movies.
supposedly in this new Fantastic Four
movie, the main villain will be Galactus,
supposedly they're casting Antonio
Banderas as Galactus.
That's a huge surprise.
the highlights?
It probably is not actually one movie,
two movies, three movies.
It's just the amount of
One that they're actually doing
Galactus really excited about that one.
Is the comic book
accurate Galactus in the MCU but also that
they go for Antonio Banderas.
Now there are probably a lot of actors
that could pull off Galactus in his voice
because most of
it would be a voiceover role.
But if you're going to do a comic book
accurate Galactus he does
have a humanoid looking form,
even though he's highly evolved.
he just happens to be a planet sized
looking person and Like
would it be Antonio Banderas,
his face in Galactus helmet with his suit?
The scales are getting better.
All is as it was.
the other obvious reason
for casting a relatively well-known,
very good actor
would be to show him as Galen of Tor so
you can learn some of Galactus backstory.
a lot of people think Galactus is going
to be another celestial in the MCU
just because he looks
so similar to the Celestials.
But he's actually very, very different.
He has a much different back story.
Galactus is a human
from the previous version of the universe.
So there's this whole cycle of Big Bang's
in the multiverse where everything dies,
contracts down.
There's
another big bank in another universe.
Another multiverse is born.
they call those the different cosmos.
We're like in the seventh
or the eighth version of the universe.
Right now, in the main MCU,
it's already happened many times.
Galactus was named Galen of Tor,
and he was one of the last survivors
of the previous version of the multiverse.
he witness it's heat death.
He's sort of like a he
who remains type of character surviving
to the very end of the multiverse
instead of being destroyed
in the process of the next Big Bang.
Like everything else, the seventh Cosmos,
sort of like the will,
the consciousness of that
entire multiverse made a contract with him
so that they could both survive
into the next cosmos,
into the next version of the multiverse.
they entered the cosmic incubation chamber
and then after the Big Bang,
the next multiverse was born,
He emerged as Galactus.
The world eater
So Galactus is kind of like a person.
Plus the essence of an entire multiverse,
all combined into one.
the funny thing about that, though,
is that doesn't
make him more powerful
than the Celestials within the comics.
At least he's actually fairly
afraid to go up against the celestial host
they usually give each other
pretty wide berth, like he lets
the Celestials do everything that they're
supposed to be doing on a cosmic scale.
Like him, the judge in the very important
cosmic purpose that Galactus serves
is kind of like Thanos plan in Avengers
Infinity War.
In Avengers Endgame,
he gets rid of dead planets
so that new life can grow in its place.
sort of in the way that farmers work with
their gardens, like they'll burn parts
of their garden to help enrich the soil
so that new life can grow.
so even though Galactus is portrayed
as a world eater and everybody hates
him, like,
Oh, you're going to destroy our world.
Actually,
he serves an important cosmic purpose
he debuted in the very early Fantastic
Four comics in a special
called The Coming of Galactus
in the reason why he came to consume
Planet Earth is because it was so enriched
with cosmic energy within the MCU.
Early theory
is that he's coming back to planet Earth
to consume it because of team.
Its body is celestial, body is full of
so much cosmic energy and resources
that he wants to consume that Originally,
Adam Driver
was going to be the MCU version
of Reed Richards.
Supposedly, the studio is still trying
to lock him down, but their backup plan is
Matt Smith.
Now, I'm a huge Matt Smith fan.
Loved his doctor
who his more dramatic movies
it is awesome
is Damon Targaryen on House of the Dragon
he and Vanessa Kirby would be
like the unhinged, crazy, horny energy
versions of the Fantastic Four.
I love it.
It would be totally nuts
that they wind up playing the characters.
I know a lot of you would just rather than
bring back John Krasinski as a616 MCU.
Reed Richards A few years ago,
I would have said the same thing,
like just bring him back
and say he's from another universe.
Who cares?
The 838 version got turned into spaghetti.
the closest.
I think they're going to revisiting
John Krasinski as a version of Reed
Richards is Deadpool three.
When Deadpool is supposedly going
to travel to the 838 universe, interact
with those versions of the X-Men,
Fantastic Four,
other Fox Marvel characters
that might be the universe
where he finds this comic book
accurate looking version of Wolverine,
since all the characters in that movie
are meant to be closer to the versions
from X-Men, Ian made its series
but played by the classic X-Men
and Fox Marvel actors.
like even Chris
Evans is supposed to have a cameo scene
as his Human Torch from the Fantastic
Four movies.
the other recent report is that Evan
Moss Rock is supposed to be playing T-Rex,
who will be the Herald of Galactus
in the movie, not Silver Surfer.
I'm assuming if they come from the 1960s,
then Galactus came for Earth
in the 1960s, and Silver Surfer
just hadn't become his Herald
at that point in the timeline yet
even though he's been fantastic
on the Bear series,
most of you will remember him as Mike Rowe
from the Marvel Netflix Punisher,
even though Punisher is coming back
during Daredevil Born again,
he's supposed to be a big character
during Daredevil Born again Season one.
I don't expect Mike Rowe to come back
or at least that version of micro,
especially if he's playing T-Rex
in the new Fantastic Four movie.
We'll get more casting news and details
soon, So I'll do more videos for the movie
when we hear
who's playing the other characters.
But big reminder
that because of the strike delays,
a lot of the actors might be dropping out
or changing for different reasons.
so the longer this drags on, the greater
the likelihood that that happens.
we'll start getting more Loki Season
two trailer soon.
In my Yosuke
episodes, we'll start in a couple weeks,
so be sure to enable alerts
from our channel
so you don't miss anything.
There'll be a bunch of other big stuff
happening to school year for that
brand new Loki season two trailer
and click here for my new Ahsoka trailer
with Luke Skywalker.
And again, Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!